KEVIN VLK: Hello everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Kevin Vlk.
And today we welcome the cast
of the Netflix original series,
"Marvel's Daredevil."
So let's bring them on up.
We have Charlie Cox, Deborah
Ann Wool, Elodie Yung,
and John Bernthal.
Very smooth guys.
Welcome.
We're so excited to
have you guys here.
Absolutely phenomenal
first season.
So now we're in season two.
Charlie, talk to us just about
what brought you to the series
and just how you guys developed
the tone of "Daredevil," season
one.
CHARLIE COX: I mean
neither of those things
really did I have much input in.
I mean, I just auditioned
like everyone else I guess.
I went through quite a rigorous
audition process, probably
the most intense audition
process I've been through.
And really the tone
of the show, I mean,
I read the scripts I knew
when I read the script,
I knew that there was
something special about them.
I was invited to go
to Disney in London
and I was in a room with
two guys whose job it
was to watch me read
the scripts and making
sure I wasn't photographing
or anything like that.
And I walked out of there and
I sent in an email to my agent
just saying I'd play
any part in this.
This is really, really special.
And then once we
started filming,
all the internal stuff is kind
of completely out of my hands.
And it wasn't until I saw
the show, I saw the trailer,
and I saw the show,
and I saw what
they had done cinematically
and all aspects of the show
from the costumes to the
cinematography and the music
and all of that,
all of that stuff,
it was all out of my control.
And I thought they did
a really wonderful job
with all that stuff.
KEVIN VLK: So what was your
take on Matt Murdock when
you go in to do the audition.
How did you look
at the character
and what was your take that
you think that won them over?
CHARLIE COX: Well
the good news is
I never read a Daredevil comic.
In fact I had this
kind of a story
I tell which is that when I got
the audition, in the email that
came from agents there was a
list of character attributes
that this guy-- it was a fake
name in the first audition.
They called him Alex.
And they said, Alex
is tall and red haired
and charismatic and strong and
sexy, all these kind of things.
And then I was working on the
audition with a friend of mine,
and they said to me in an email,
they think this is Daredevil.
And the guy said, I think
this guy, I think he's blind.
And I was like no, no,
no, definitely not.
I'm pretty sure they would have
told me if the guy was blind.
But then getting the part,
I guess what was good
was I was able to
read the scripts
and get a sense tonally what
the show was going to be like
and who this character was in
those original Drew Goddard
episodes, one and
two of last year.
And then I was able to take that
knowledge and go to the comics
and sift through
them all and find
the different runs and
the different illustrators
and writers who best
captured what I think
the show was trying to do.
And then I could
concentrate on them.
So there's a wonderful series.
There's lots of great
series, but there's
a particular run of issues by
Brian Bendis and Alex Maleev
that I concentrated on.
And I felt like they
suited the show that
was being written very well.
KEVIN VLK: It was phenomenal.
I think it blew everyone
away because the tone of it
is much more mature and much
more adult and gory and just so
freaking awesome.
And so Deborah--
CHARLIE COX: You a fan?
KEVIN VLK: Little bit.
Little bit.
Little bit of a fanboy.
But Deborah, then you did
phenomenal in season one
as well.
And you're back in season
two as Deborah-- that's
your name-- as Karen Page.
And tell us about where
your character is now
after season one and what
she's doing in season two?
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: Sure.
I mean, I think we meet
Karen sort of broken.
And we see her trying
to build up from that.
But of course we end in a
very dramatic place as well.
So I think we're
allowed to say we
skip six months between
the first season
and the second season.
And so I think we start
with our sort of Scooby gang
in a good place.
Things are going well and
they're happy with each other.
But because of this one,
stuff quickly goes awry.
KEVIN VLK: Jon.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: Which
was true on set as well.
Jon came in and everything
just went to hell.
That's what happened.
JON BERNTHAL: That's it, yeah.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: I mean,
it's hard to talk about
without giving anything away,
but I think Karen's grappling
with what she did last year.
People talk a lot about
how it's so funny or it's
so bad that Matt and Foggy
are keeping the secret
that Matt is
Daredevil from Karen.
I'm like, but Karen has got
two big secrets, one of which
is I killed the guy that
she is keeping from them.
So she's got to deal
with that I think.
KEVIN VLK: I gotcha.
And Elodie, Jon, welcome to
the Marvel and Netflix family.
This is awesome.
I think people were freaking
out about season two
and what characters
were they going to be?
Was it going Elektra?
Oh, we have Elektra.
We got to have-- I
think Bullseye was one
that the fans were
really pushing for.
And then when
Punisher got out, it
was like oh, who are they
going to case as Punisher?
And I think a lot of people
were pushing for Thomas Jane
because of what he did
in his past series.
And then when you
were cast, I think
everyone was like, oh
my god, it's perfect.
It's absolutely perfect casting.
And so Jon, can talk about, did
you study the character before?
Did you know about it?
Did you actively pursue it?
Or was it one of
those things you
were even surprised they
were coming to you for it?
JON BERNTHAL: No.
I, like Charlie, audition
came from my agents.
Charlie and I actually have
had the same wonderful agent.
CHARLIE COX: Like
a package deal.
JON BERNTHAL: It's
an iconic character,
so obviously I had some
sort of sense of who he was.
But kind of digging
into the source material
was a real joy, a
real pleasure for me.
And I think that there's
been many iterations
of the character, but
I feel like I found
his main kind of conflict.
And the crux of what I think
he's really going through,
to me, it came right
from the comics.
And I feel like because so
many of the different lines
of comics, Punisher
comics that came out,
they're delivered
in soliloquy form.
It's perfect fodder for acting.
But once I saw season one and
I saw what these guys did,
I saw that really, to me,
it wasn't a superhero show,
but it was a character study.
And it was such a human
show and such an honest show
and raw show, I thought
it was the perfect sort
of stage for this character
to be brought back.
So I'm unbelievably honored
and grateful to have
the opportunity.
KEVIN VLK: Was there's some
nervousness about taking
on this kind of character?
And you guys, I mean,
you guys are not
exactly friends for the majority
of this, from what I can tell.
In just the trailers and just
seeing some of the episodes
already, you guys are
fighting a little bit.
But you guys actually have
some of the same goals
it seems like too.
JON BERNTHAL: Yeah, I
think as you'll see,
literally in the same
conversation where
I was welcomed to Marvel, I
was told, keep your mouth shut.
So they're very
clear about that.
So I'm not going
to give much away.
Again, I think these
characters, they're iconic.
And they matter so
much to so many people.
So there's an enormous
amount of pressure
and a real desire to
not mess this thing up,
especially when you have a show
that was so good in season one.
The bar was set high.
KEVIN VLK: For sure,
you did a great job
skirting that question.
Elodie, tell us about Elektra.
Everyone's excited.
It was referenced
a little bit, very,
very briefly in season one.
And now you're freaking
Elektra and you're back.
So tell us about the
character and your take on it.
ELODIE YUNG: What do
want to know about her?
KEVIN VLK: So how about your
relationship, because there's
a little bit of romance
it seems from some
of the trailers with
these two over here.
And then all of a
sudden you come in.
ELODIE YUNG: I don't know if
Elektra really likes that.
We meet Elektra at this
point 10 years after Matthew
and her left each
other or broke up.
So it's an old flame.
It's her first love.
And Elektra probably misses
Matthew a little bit.
So that's why maybe she
comes back into his life.
I can't say much
really about it.
I believe that she misses
him as much as she needs him
for some stuff.
CHARLIE COX: Not
that kind of stuff.
ELODIE YUNG: And
it was just great
for me to get to play this
incredible, interesting, crazy,
wild character.
And like my colleagues, I
didn't know much about her.
It was just a completely
new game field for me.
And it was very interesting for
me to get to read the comics
and build this
fantastic character.
I had a lot of fun doing it.
And I hope people will like
her as much as I loved her.
KEVIN VLK: And what did
you bring to the character?
Did you know any-- I mean,
she's amazing in the series
and her fighting skills.
Did you have any
training before or did
you have to go through really
crazy intense training?
ELODIE YUNG: You know,
I have to be honest,
we don't have the
time really to train.
I mean Charlie's very
committed to his work.
I'm a bit more lazy.
We had to pick up things
like this, on the spot.
Thankfully, we were surrounded
by amazing, amazing stunt guys.
And I've practiced karate
and all these martial arts
back in the day.
So I could pick
up choreographies.
But yeah, we had days
where we had to go
through the whole fight scenes.
And it was painful,
but also you're
so happy when you
see the result.
I think it's incredible
what they did.
And I'm proud that
I was able to do it.
So no training for me, but still
I had to do the fights, yes.
CHARLIE COX: I feel like
I have to add that she's
incredible at that stuff.
She's got a black belt in three
different martial arts and kung
fu.
ELODIE YUNG: No, just one.
They
CHARLIE COX: Show
the choreography
and she adds to it.
I mean, she's amazing.
KEVIN VLK: That's great.
And Charlie and Deborah, you
guys, coming into season two,
you guys have new
showrunners on it.
Can you talk about
the differences
and what they brought to it.
Because I think, were they
writers on the season one,
right?
And so what did they bring
as actual showrunners
and taking "Daredevil"
to the next level?
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: I feel
very safe in their hands.
I feel like they
love these characters
the same way that we do.
Because when you take on a
character like this, you do,
you start to love them like
you love a little sister
or a little brother.
And you want to
protect them and also
make sure that they're well
rounded and three dimensional.
So it was nice, every time I
ever spoke with Doug and Marco,
I felt that they cared
about Karen as much as I did
and wanted to do right by her.
So that enthusiasm--
KEVIN VLK: Was
there a little bit
that you could play
with a little bit more
with Deborah-- or with Karen.
I keep calling her Deborah.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: Funny.
KEVIN VLK: Usually it's
the opposite, right?
With the Karen character,
because if you change too much
of Daredevil or you change
too much of the Punisher,
people get a little upset.
But with Karen, did you have
a little more freedom to do--
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: Karen is
almost two distinctly different
characters in the comic books.
I mean, she kind of
started as one thing
and ended as a
completely different one.
So I know what we wanted to
do was find our own Karen.
And maybe that did give us a
little more freedom with her
that her backstory can be
anything that we want it to be.
We don't necessarily
have to follow
what has been done before.
KEVIN VLK: She has a
very mysterious past.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL:
It's so exciting.
I know everything.
KEVIN VLK: You know it.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL:
I know everything.
I haven't even told these guys.
KEVIN VLK: And you know
Charlie, Catholicism is
a huge part of the character.
And it's unique because it's not
really part of any other Marvel
character.
They're not really
tied to a religion.
But it's this battle of,
he's trying to do good,
but he's doing bad.
He's asking for forgiveness
for not what he's done
but what he's about to do.
So the role of religion
with the character,
how is that shaping him,
and where does that kind of
find him in season
two at the battles
that he's facing
with Jon's character?
CHARLIE COX: I mean, I think
it's still very much there.
It's still very much like a kind
of a shadow over his shoulder.
In the first season, the way
that the first season was
structured, Matt
was kind of obsessed
with this man and the finding
of this man and the belief
that if he could bring
this one guy to justice,
everything else would
kind of fall into place.
And in that process there
was a lot of time where
he didn't have a next move.
He didn't know what else to do.
And so there was a
lot of time for him
to spend in his apartment
and with those feelings
and with that guilt, that
Catholic guilt, and wondering
about, does he have the right
to do this because his gifts are
in some ways God given?
And at the same time, is he kind
of playing god, if you like.
This season I think that those
feelings are still there.
It's just that the
season is structured,
there's so much happens to Matt.
I mean, he's pulled in so
many different directions.
And he's got the Punisher.
There's different
gangs, Irish gangs.
There's biker gangs involved.
Elektra shows up.
He's trying to kind of find
a vulnerability with Karen.
It just goes so crazy for him
that he almost didn't have time
to think about that stuff.
So in a way, it's still there
and it's still hopefully
present in his thinking
and in his feelings,
but it's not something that we
investigate to the same degree
as we did last year.
KEVIN VLK: I got you.
And Introducing
two huge characters
with the Punisher and
Elektra, but this is still
Matt Murdock's story.
And so what was the
balance of that,
just making sure that
everyone got their proper time
on screen, but develop their
stories, their backstories,
but still keeping it
Matt's kind of [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLIE COX: The honest
answer is I don't know,
because I wasn't really privy
to any of those conversations.
I'm sure those are conversations
that happened in the writers
room and with the show
runners and with Netflix
and that stuff.
But that's not really my job.
My job is just to
read the scripts
and kind of bring
these moments-- make
this journey and these scenes
as truthful as possible.
It's kind of related,
but what I will say
is what I thought the
writers did spectacularly
well this year is that
obviously the show had
a degree of success.
And so we want to kind
of keep the same idea.
We want to maintain
the tone of the show
and many aspects of the show.
But we also want to do
something new, second season.
And what they did really
wonderfully well was whereas
for the first season there was
this drive towards this one guy
who was kind of the villain.
He was the big bad.
And the good and evil was kind
of maybe a little bit clearer
last year.
And this year it's not the case.
You know, Frank
Castle was kind of
known as an antihero
rather than a villain.
And although initially
when he shows up, I think
Matt would like to
pigeonhole Frank Castle.
He'd like to say, well this
is another Wilson Fisk.
He needs to be put away.
He needs to be taken care of.
And what Karen suggests
quite early on to Matt
is that actually maybe
they're very similar.
Maybe they're cut
from the same cloth.
And that idea, that
concept is anathema to Matt
because it means
that if that's true,
then really, well he's
responsible for all
this mayhem, and he
needs to kind of hang up
the suit, which is
probably the thing
he wants to do least of all.
KEVIN VLK: And so Jon, in your
character with Frank Castle,
the Punisher-- you were
phenomenal in "Fury,"
in David Ayer's "Fury."
Because Frank Castle is a little
similar in that he's a war
veteran and he's-- was there
anything that you brought from
"Fury" or you learned from
that film that you brought
into the character?
JON BERNTHAL: Thanks.
I think you have to bring so
much of yourself to each part.
And I think that these are all--
it's kind of a hokey answer,
but these are all part of your
sort of collective experience.
And I think that "Fury," that
experience with those guys
and with David is really
burned into my soul.
So yeah, I think part
of the military aspect
and part of the training, I'm
sure, really came in handy.
I just think this whole
thing is different.
I think this is the
age of television.
And there's no place
that I'd rather be.
It's an unbelievable
opportunity.
And I think the
Netflix model, it
gives you the
opportunity, I think,
to really be bold enough
to abandon the audience
and turn your back on them.
And I think with a
character like this,
I think, look, we're telling
the story of Matt Murdock.
And I think for me to be
able to play this character
and know that I can do something
so deplorable and so full
on that the audience-- you can
go as far to say I genuinely
do not care if the audience
completely abandons
this character because in two,
three episodes down the road,
I get a chance to win them back.
And the cool thing is they're
not waiting two or three
weeks for that episode.
And so it was constantly
sort of this push,
especially having
the freedom of it
not being your
character's story,
you can really sort of
push the envelope there.
And I think that you don't
get those opportunities
I feel like in film.
KEVIN VLK: And just from
you guys' perspective,
coming into the superhero
realm now and superhero movies
and what the show is, it's
just completely, completely
different.
So what do you think the
impact-- or what surprised you
about what the show has done
with the superhero genre.
Because like I said, it's
something completely different.
Even though it's still in
the MCU, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, it's
completely different.
ELODIE YUNG: For me, it doesn't
really feel like [INAUDIBLE]
to step in a superhero world
because the writing is so good.
And this project,
it's so characters
driven that you just feel
that you-- it's very grounded.
And I think none
of our characters
are these superheroes
or the villains that
are saving the world.
It just feels that
there's so much
of ourselves in these characters
and will from the writers
to make them more humans
that it doesn't feel really
like a superhero show.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: Well I think
for me along those lines,
it's the idea of consequences.
That when the bad guys
are Nazis or aliens,
you can kind of kill
indiscriminately
because they're evil.
And so that's over.
But our villains, if you
want to call them that,
are human beings.
You know, Fisk thought he
was doing the best that he
could for his community.
And Frank Castle
thinks that he's
going to take down
the people who are
making this world a bad place.
I like that our show doesn't--
it stays in the gray.
It doesn't try to label.
KEVIN VLK: We'll be
taking audience questions
in a few minutes if you guys
want to start lining up.
Being in that and
being so different,
and it's amazing
because you guys aren't
gods or super soldiers or have
Stark technology or anything
like that.
But you're still in that world.
And this is hypothetical.
This is the geekiness, is if
you were to join the Avengers--
hypothetical, because you
guys can't talk about it.
But hypothetically,
if you were to,
what could your characters
actually bring to help them?
DEBORAH ANN WOLL:
No, I think it's--
KEVIN VLK: Hypothetically.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL:
They're saving the world,
and Matt Murdock is
defending the crap out
of 10 blocks of Manhattan.
Like, that his role.
CHARLIE COX: If you
read "Civil War,"
Daredevil is in "Civil War."
And if you read, if you were to
isolate the panels that include
Daredevil from "Civil
War," from those issues,
It's the same Daredevil that
we have on our show I think.
Because he's in the background.
He's aware that he doesn't
quite have the same powers
as the other guys in the room.
So he's a little bit moody
and he's in the background.
And he kind of makes sinister
comments every now and again
and puts everyone
in their place.
And he's kind of a key
element in the whole way
that that story
unfolds, in the way
that his abilities
allow him to be.
When you read that comic, you
don't question it tonally.
So I don't see how that
would be a problem.
So put us in The Avengers.
KEVIN VLK: You guys
just remaining silent.
You've got this down Jon.
We'll start with Elodie.
What are your
characters-- we'll go down
the line-- what are your
characters' greatest weakness?
ELODIE YUNG: At
first when I started
working on this character, I
really had no clue who she was.
And I did some research
and read the comics,
and then I came across an
interview of Frank Miller.
And he said that,
for him, Elektra-- it
wasn't the case of
finding out if she
was a good girl or
a bad girl, but she
was one of those villains who
have a weak streak in them.
And so I was wondering, what
was this weakness, this failure?
And I believe that it's the
love she once had for Matthew.
I think it's really what
makes her a bit more
human than the sociopath that
the writers wanted me to be.
And I really tried to bring this
in my character in this season.
I think that's her weakness,
the love that she--
And you find it in the comics.
She left the world she
didn't believe in because
of the death of her dad.
And she tried really
to get rid of Matthew
because that was
the only thing that
would attach her to this past.
So I think that's
really her weakness.
She's capable of love, as much
as she's capable of killing,
of course.
But she is capable of love.
KEVIN VLK: Jon?
JON BERNTHAL: Look,
a couple of things.
I think what first
jumps into my mind
and I think what just
sort of thematically
what we're talking
about about this show
and I think what makes
this show really powerful
is that it's not
about, like we said,
it's not about superheroes.
It's a really human
centered show.
And I think in any human
being, the thing that
makes you the most
powerful is also
what makes you the most weak.
And what you love about
people, often times,
is very much cousin to what
you could hate about them.
And I think with Frank,
he has no superpower.
He's really, really,
really, angry.
He's got a lot of range.
And it's what makes
him so strong.
He's not the best fighter.
He does not have
any super strength.
But you better kill him.
Because of that, that's
also his weakness.
I think that he's so driven
and this mission that he's on
is so unbelievably personal.
And I think that Frank
Castle that you're
going to see in season
two of "Daredevil"
is not necessarily
the Punisher yet.
I think you're going
to see a guy who is not
really concerned with the
safety of Hell's Kitchen,
not really concerned with
ridding the world of bad guys.
He is trying to find the
people that killed his family
and kill them in the
most brutal way possible.
That's his mission, and
it's very, very personal.
And morality, consequence,
right or wrong,
all that's out the window.
So that's also puts him in an
extremely vulnerable position
because he may do things
that-- at the end of the day,
he is a human being.
And he may end up doing
things there that he regret
and that completely do not go
along with what he believes in.
And I think what these
writers were smart enough
to do is you have a character
who's put so much time
and effort in building this
wall around his morality
and making himself as
impenetrable as possible,
but I think what's cool is these
great characters around him
penetrate that wall.
And at the end of the
day, he is a human being.
So it's a long ass answer
to a short ass question.
KEVIN VLK: It's great.
And really quickly,
it's interesting,
because you were saying
about the fighting,
he's not the best
fighter and stuff.
It's really interesting
to see your character,
Matt Murdock, Daredevil,
try to fight him,
because he has
guns and something
like he's never handled before.
It's just interesting
because they've
changed your fight style.
They've change his approach to
actually taking down enemies.
It's been pretty interesting.
More of a statement I
guess than a question.
Back to Deborah.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: Honestly, I'm
so floored by that question.
I don't know, it
really got to me.
I feel like in our identities,
in our sense of ourselves,
we have our two sides.
We have the side
that we wish we are,
the side that we
hope that we are,
and then we have the side
that we're afraid is true.
And I think about
that a lot with Karen.
I think about that a lot.
I think about how there's the
person that she wants to be
and the heroes that
she sees around him
and being terribly,
terribly afraid
that she will never live up
to that, that she will never
be the person that
she wants to be.
That this person who
can stop injustice--
I think about this season
and the corruption,
and the word that comes
to mind is impotence,
this feeling that there
is nothing I can do.
As hard as I try, I'm a bitch.
As hard as I try, I am pushy.
As hard as I try, I'm impotent.
I have no power.
I have no control.
And it's heartbreaking.
And I feel like that
doubt, that fear,
is Karen's weakness,
that it keeps her
from feeling like
she has any power
or any-- can change anything.
And that's why she looks up
to people like Daredevil.
And I wish she could
see it in herself.
And I think I'm emotional
because I probably
have some-- this is me too.
This is my little sister too.
But yeah, that's my long answer.
KEVIN VLK: Well, follow that.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
JON BERNTHAL: Deal with that.
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLIE COX: Yeah I was just
thinking, god, [INAUDIBLE].
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: I'm so sorry.
CHARLIE COX: You know, I'm
going to go relatively quickly
because I'd love to get to the--
I think that Matt's biggest
weakness probably is that--
probably the worst thing that
could have happened to Matt was
defeating Wilson Fisk because
with every day that passes,
with every successful night
out bringing people down,
he's getting more arrogant.
There's more of
a swagger to him.
There's more confidence.
There's more feeling
of invincibility.
And he's more convinced that
he can do this by himself.
And I think what he's going to
have to learn at some point--
maybe this season, maybe
not-- that he can't.
There you go.
KEVIN VLK: Wonderful.
Yep, you.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
I want to say thank
you so much for coming here.
I just want to ask, while you
all were working on the show,
did you feel there are any
differences because of Netflix
versus shows you worked
on another network
like HBO or AMC?
CHARLIE COX: I think there are
tremendous differences, yeah.
The main one, the thing
I noticed first of all,
was the start of writing.
Because it's not
appointment television,
you don't have to spend any time
at the beginning of an episode
or at the end of an episode
either reminding people what
happened before or creating
enough of a dramatic ending
so that you will
bring people back.
You'll put that
thing in someone that
says I've got to find out what
happened to those characters.
You know what I mean?
And so you're gaining an
extra five, 10 minutes
either side of an episode
where you can just
continue telling story, continue
being with the characters.
And you can allow it to kind
of flow more succinctly.
I said once before,
it feels more
like a kind of a 13
hour movie than it
does episodic television.
And the other thing is what
they're discovering on Netflix,
more and more as well even
as more shows come out,
is that we don't have to conform
to what we know as television.
We can do what we want.
They can do what they want.
So an episode now doesn't
have to be a set time.
It doesn't have to come in at
55 minutes with enough time
for commercial breaks.
It can be anywhere from
35 minutes to 55 minutes.
When you turn on
Netflix, you can watch
that episode of television.
You'll see every episode
is a different length.
So you can edit each
episode so that it
works best, that story in
that one hour works best,
without having to kind
of find a few minutes
or lose a few minutes
to make the time.
I just think all that
makes for just much more
kind of creative work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So another
new Netflix show
has come out about a superhero
since the first season
of "Daredevil" was
released, "Jessica Jones."
And I'm wondering if you guys
are fans of Jessica Jones
and if we'll see her at all
in "Daredevil" this season
or potentially in the future.
KEVIN VLK: Well you guys have
"The Defenders" coming up.
This is all leading up to the
big team up of "The Defenders."
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: No comment.
KEVIN VLK: No comment.
AUDIENCE: Are you
guys at least fans?
CHARLIE COX: Yeah, I
love "Jessica Jones."
I thought it was fantastic.
And I don't really want
to hog another question,
but what I would say
is having seen it
and recognize that
how totally different
it is from the first
season of "Daredevil"
and how brilliant it is, I'm so
interested to see how those two
characters, that world
combines, including
the world that they create
for Luke Cage and Iron Fist.
I think that's going to
answer a lot of the questions
that people have about whether
it works within The Avengers,
because those two shows
were very different.
But I think we can
see how they will
exist in the same universe.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I love the show.
Thank you so much for coming.
It's great to see you guys.
I actually live
in Hell's Kitchen
and it's a super pleasant
and safe place [INAUDIBLE].
So it's really fun to watch
the show and look out my window
and go, OK, whatever.
My main question
is, you guys have
such complicated and amazing
fighting choreography
during the show, especially
kind of thinking back
to that one ridiculous hallway
scene where Daredevil is just
really beating up
a ton of people.
When you guys are
doing really big scenes
like that where you want
it to kind of be one shot,
how much time and
preparation and practice
do you guys go through, and how
many takes do you guys end up?
Specifically for that
one scene, how many
takes before you actually
got the final cut?
And then as a
follow up, Charlie,
how well can you actually
see through that mask
that you wear during the show?
Before the red suit of course.
CHARLIE COX: So great question.
So the first thing I will say
is, Phil Silvera, our stunt
coordinator, a genius.
My stunt double, Chris Brewster,
is as an extraordinary human
being, as well as being one
of the nicest people I've ever
met.
I mean, some of the stuff
he pulls, it's like--
I remember saying a
cut piece of footage
from one of the
episodes last year
and thinking that
they'd slowed it
down or something,
because I didn't
realize a human being could
sat in the air as long as that.
But they didn't.
As Elodie said, we
get very little time.
The stunt team are
rehearsing through the week.
We're shooting other scenes.
And then we come in and we
learn most of the fights.
It's shot as you would shoot a
scene, so it's shot in pieces.
So I'm able to learn between
six and 10 moves at once.
And I learn that as best I can.
We shoot that and we move
onto the next section.
And we go about it that way.
The fight that you're referring
to in season one was one take.
And what was cool
about that was we
spent the whole morning--
we had a day to do it.
We spent the whole morning
just rehearsing the camera
movements, so just basically
plotting the action.
And it was just all
about the camera.
We then started shooting it.
And take two or three
was pretty good.
We got through it,
you know what I mean?
And everyone was like,
that was pretty good.
And then someone went, I think
we could probably do better.
And then at midnight,
we were still there.
And we were like
literally on our--
because it's a long take-- we
were either on our 12th or 13th
take.
And we were like OK,
we'll do it one more time.
Chris Brewster got
injured at one point
and we weren't sure if was
going to be able to continue.
And we did one more
and that was the one.
It just all came into place.
And the thing I always think
is memorable about that scene,
and it's something that
we kind of- maybe this
isn't true-- but I was
thinking we kind of stumbled
upon it accidentally,
was that Daredevil
and the other characters
need time to breathe.
They get out of breath.
And there's moments where
both of them are kind of,
they know they've got to
go back at each other,
but they're prolonging
it because they're
catching their breath.
And that was true
because it was happening.
You know what I mean?
They were trying to give
themselves as much time.
And I think that's
what a fight is like.
You can't keep going like that.
You are destroyed.
And I think that that may change
how people do fight scenes
in-- stop looking at
your watch-- change
how people do things
in the future.
KEVIN VLK: That wasn't for you.
Got Netflix looking at me.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys,
huge fan of the show.
I was just wondering,
so obviously Wilson Fisk
gets locked up at the
end of season one.
Can we expect for him to
make a cameo in season two
or in the upcoming seasons?
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: No comment.
CHARLIE COX: We literally
can't answer that question.
AUDIENCE: And the next
question is for you Jon.
Being that your character
uses such military precision,
can you tell us
a little bit more
about what you did to
prepare for the role?
JON BERNTHAL: I mean as far as
the physicality and the weapons
training, I think when
you prepare for a part,
it's twofold, right?
There's all the physical stuff.
There's how is he going to walk?
How is he going to talk?
How is he going to handle the
familiarity with the props,
the weapons, and
so on and so forth?
But then there's the
real deal preparation.
And that's the diving
in, the emotional stuff.
And I've said before, I'm
a husband and I'm a father.
And I think that
there's no way I
could begin to even attempt
to tackle this part until I
got there.
I think until I really
realized and know
in my bones what it's like to
love people so much more than I
love myself and so willingly
would give up my life for them,
how can I begin to imagine what
it would be like for this man
if somebody took his family?
And what that
requires, for me, is
going to a really, really scary,
really, really dark place.
And since it scared the living
shit out of me, I was like,
I really got to do this.
I really got to try this.
But that's where it kind of all
sort of starts with me is that.
Sorry, that doesn't
answer your question,
but that's where-- yeah.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
KEVIN VLK: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Hey guys.
Thank you for coming along.
It's been a pleasure seeing
you guys answer questions
and discuss them.
One question for
you Karen is, being
in the middle from the
perspective of seeing Daredevil
do what he does in
helping out the community,
but also in season two
seeing Punisher kind of exact
his revenge of what the
normal citizen would
want if he was in that
predicament of losing someone,
how do you feel her
character interprets
the right moral
choice as [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLIE COX: Oh, great question.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: I mean, you've
hit upon Karen's storyline
for season two, essentially.
I think if you
look at someone who
has this questionable
past-- we're not
quite sure what
that is, but we do
know about what
happened with Wesley.
Now if the whole world looks
at Frank Castle and says,
he's a monster, then
Karen's a monster.
If the whole world
looks at Daredevil
and says Daredevil's a hero,
well, Karen took it too far.
So I think she looks at
these examples of people
who are doing
things in her life,
and she has to determine
for herself whether she
thinks what she did was right.
And it's an
unanswerable question.
I mean, there is
no answer to that.
It's not right,
and it's not wrong.
And she was in a situation that
none of us-- we hope none of us
will ever be in.
So I think I can go so far to
say that Karen is fascinated
by Frank Castle and what he
means, what he represents,
because in some ways
he represents her.
AUDIENCE: Thank so much.
KEVIN VLK: Thank you.
Great question.
And quickly, because
I know you guys
got to go, just through your
guys' development from season
one now to season two, and now
you guys joining on season two,
just from the beginning
of that to the end, what
did you find in your characters
that surprised you the most
or that excited you the most
about each of your characters?
ELODIE YUNG: You looking at me?
KEVIN VLK: I'm
looking right at you.
You haven't spoken in a while.
ELODIE YUNG: I don't think there
is one thing I could pick from
this character that
really [NON-ENGLISH]--
stands out more for me.
It's not English,
but you guys got it.
You know, Elektra is
such a complex character.
For me, just having
the opportunity
to get to know what-- just go
back to the essence of Elektra
and discover this
world of comics
was something new and
fascinating for me.
Trying to capture the essence
and put it in this character
that we built for the
show was exciting.
I talked a lot with
the writers, and they
wanted her to be a sociopath.
So I had to do some
homework and really
trying to find out
what a sociopath is.
Yeah, playing someone that
seemed to be very cold,
that has no remorse, no sense
of guilt, no sense of empathy
or who doesn't care about
the well-being of others,
that was something actually
pretty interesting for me.
All this aspect, all this
side was really good.
But then tapping into my own
emotions and my own experience
to bring some of her more human
side and some of this failure
that I talked about with this
relationship and this love
she had once for
Matthew, that was also
very-- that was great
as an actress to do that
as well, in some scenes.
So the whole thing.
I mean, I just love
Elektra, and that's it.
It was just good for me.
It was really good.
JON BERNTHAL: What surprised me?
I think that he's in
such a dark sort of cloud
of rage and anger, but
within that, his ability
to be not just tactical
in terms of how he fights,
but psychologically tactical.
And he's got the
ability to manipulate.
And he can be cunning.
And that was a pleasant surprise
that they let me kind of play
with that, I guess
his intelligence.
DEBORAH ANN WOLL: I
won't cry this time.
I, Deborah, am sort of a
silly, dare I say dorky person.
And I never really saw
much room for that in Karen
at the beginning.
She seemed like
such a serious sort
of intelligent minded person.
And this year I
think I was surprised
I was able to find more
of that aspect of myself
in it, that there
were moments where
she felt a little awkward.
I feel like she cannot keep
her cool around Matt Murdock.
And there are some
really fun moments
that I can't talk
about too specifically
where serious, serious
things were happening.
And then we did a
scene following it,
and there were moments where
I found myself cracking jokes
that I didn't even know
were in the script,
and sort of laughing in them.
And I don't know, it was a
surprising, cool thing to find.
CHARLIE COX: A
really good question.
The thing that sprung to
mind was that, I guess,
what surprised me
about the character,
but also I think about all
characters, all people,
is that we're kind of
walking contradictions,
you know, and we can
simultaneously believe
two very, very opposite things.
I think it's a Kris
Kristofferson song where
he says we're walking
contradictions
or something like those things.
And I think with
Matt that's probably
the thing that confuses
the most is that he's
one person with Karen.
And that is very true.
That is very authentic.
That is really how he believes
and what he wants in life.
And then he's a very
different person with Elektra.
That side of himself is
also valid, is also real.
And yet if, as an
outsider, if you
were to see those
behaviors, you would say,
that guy's a hypocrite.
But I'm not sure
that that's true.
And I think often we relate to
those kind of things as people.
KEVIN VLK: Great.
Well thank you guys so
much for being here.
CHARLIE COX: Thanks
so much guys.
KEVIN VLK: "Daredevil,"
season two, is only on Netflix
March 18, globally.
So check it out.
It's awesome.
CHARLIE COX: Thanks for coming.
KEVIN VLK: Thank
you guys so much.